hello there glad to see you all here
enjoying PI data did you go to the
opening talk yeah brilliant stuff being
done with Python in the notebook now
there were a couple of talks in Python
Italy on the same topic and I think it
was very significant that - the the
thing that I thought was was really most
interesting was when he said that Python
is now cool and you recruit people by
letting them use Python I thought that
the fact that that that opinion of
Python has made it into the into the
scientific world is is brilliant so just
before we start a quick introduction
I've been programming for a very long
time since 1960 mumble and I started
using Python about 20 years ago in the
mid-1990s I have actually taught Python
classes for a bit and for 20 years I
spent in the States
principally consulting I started a
conference called PyCon in the USA which
is still going to this day and I've
tried to invest some time in increasing
pythons popularity by being a director
and chairing the Python Software
Foundation so I am actually a Python
nutcase and I'm currently employed as
chief technology officer for a fin tech
startup called BM ll technologies in
London here I moved back from the states
in fact one year ago today so everything
that is in this talk is available and I
think if we can flip across oh that's
very interesting yeah ok so there's a
what happened there there's a github
repository where's my cursor gone and so
what we have in that github repository I
can bring it up there we go so besides
the usual readme
I've got the slides which are available
not only in the original PowerPoint form
but also as PDFs because fewer and fewer
people now are using PowerPoint and
there is an ipython notebook that I can
use to actually show you the code
executing make sure that you know that
I'm not trying to pull the wool over
your eyes and that's actually available
in two forms there's the one I'm gonna
be using in the presentation which is
pretty much just the code with a few
headings and then there's an annotated
version which kind of expands on the
material so that you can read it as you
execute the code so it's still got all
the code in and just in case there's
anyone in the room that hasn't installed
Jupiter yet I have included an HTML
version of the notebook file so that you
can just view it without worrying too
much about having to install any
software so that's the annotated version
of the note but but what I'm going to be
trying to do is as I go through I'll
actually be using that notebook to help
me demonstrate executable code very
happy to have questions as we go through
the the talk there is as you know
probably a short question and answer
session unfortunately I can't stay for
the rest of the day so if you do have
any questions that you want to ask me
afterwards please but know me straight
after the talk because I can't stay long
My partner retired last week and and
we've we've got 20 people coming to a
party and I've got to cook for them so
unfortunately they're I won't be able to
stay for the the rest of the day so a
quick word about iteration basically
what you're trying to do when you
iterate over something in python is say
take the same action with every one of a
number of objects and so typically what
we're really talking about is use of the
for keyword and the traditional use of
the four keywords in the four statement
but if you know enough Python then
you've also come across comprehensions
like Liston and
comprehensions and so all of those uses
of the four key word involve pythons
iteration mechanism so just in case you
worried or concerned about it or
wondering about it this material doesn't
apply to while loops which are using an
entirely different mechanism and much
simpler mechanism for looping so Python
originally used to do for loops back in
the days before you could iterate over
dictionaries and back in the day when
when life was simpler effectively by
simply using the get item method so what
it would do is the this is pseudocode I
mean this is not what you actually had
to do this is what the interpreter did
when you wrote you know for I sorry for
yeah for I in test lists then it would
set some private index variable to zero
and then it would loop and it would try
to access the next value in the item and
it would do that by using the dunder get
item method which if you're not familiar
with it is the method that's called when
you subscript something so basically
what it's trying to do is it's trying to
increase access successive values in the
list so if we have a list called test
list then it will issue get item zero
and then it will do the loop body with
the get item with with item zero it will
increment the value it'll go around and
eventually you'll get to the end of the
list and so the get item will raise an
index error the interpreter will break
out of the loop and that that is the end
of your for loop with a few minor
details like you know if the for loop
actually broke with a break then you you
don't do the else various things like
that but that's the the essence of how
Python used to do indexing and in fact
we can see in the ipython notebook I've
defined a few values here so we're just
there defining a simple
function to represent doing something
with things and a sample list so here is
that actual code now and you can see
that if I execute that code it does
indeed
iterate over the list so you all know
pythons very good at backwards
compatibility and even to this day
backwards compatibility is available so
we can actually write an iterable if we
want of our own that uses that mechanism
so here I'm defining a stars class and
the idea behind the Stars class is that
the instances are initialized with an
integer value and basically it will
produce a sequence of values increasing
so get item in this case it uses the
index value to determine the number of
stars that it returns so if I execute
that declaration and then I create an
instance of stars for and I iterate over
it what will happen will be I'll just
have to scroll that up a little bit so
you can see that the get item method is
called with an index value of 0 first so
the value returns the star an empty
string then get item is called with 1 so
it returns the string with 1 star and so
on and so forth until eventually get
item is called with an index value of 5
and of course with an index value of 5
it raises index error and so the the
loop stops so that mechanism has been
available since about Python 1.5
something like that it's certainly a
very old mechanism but around about the
2.2 stage ok we because we've just
discussed all that around about the 2.2
stage they decided that they didn't like
those those that mechanism for number
of reasons I mean it has got limitations
like you have to have a get item method
which takes numerical value and those
indices must actually run from 0 up
through maximum value so the real
problem there is that you can only use
that protocol to iterate over ordered
containers so it didn't work with Dix it
didn't work with sets anything that
wasn't numerically accessible by index
wasn't iterable in Python and so the
developers being anxious to make the
language as good as they could
introduced a new mechanism and they said
ok when we try and iterate over
something the for loop looks to see
whether the object that we're iterating
over has a dunder itter method under it
er by the ways the way I pronounced
underscore underscore it an underscore
underscore is just an abbreviation the
syntactic abbreviation so if the object
that you're iterating over has done
dorita method then the interpreter will
actually call that method and save the
result of it and then as it goes round
the loop it produces the next value for
the iteration by calling this object
this newly created object dunder next
method and if you're using Python 2
there's a little glitch in the design
there because they originally called the
the method next with node unders but
then they realizes they move well in
fact they realized very quickly
afterwards there's been a mistake but in
Python 3 its properly recognized as a
magic method so if that call to the next
method raises a stop iteration exception
then the loop terminates so that's what
we do
in the new protocol if the if there's a
dunder method on the object if there is
no dunder itter method then basically it
just falls back to the original get item
based mechanism that we were discussing
and as I've already demonstrate
did that mechanism works perfectly well
even in Python three point I think I'm
running Python 3.4 on this particular
demonstration so the these new types of
objects those are called iterables an
iterable has a dunder itta method but it
will not have a dunder next method
because remember the for loop uses the
result of calling dunder itter
to call the next method on that it
doesn't call the next method on the
iterable object itself so if you look at
lists and tuples and dicts and sets and
many other types of object in python in
fact some of them that we don't normally
create ourselves but they're created by
mechanisms within the language in short
basically anything you might want to
iterate over Python has provided the
iteration mechanism for and so they are
iterables
so the pseudocode for the new iteration
protocol here we're trying to iterate
over test lists again so in this case we
call tests lists it a method and then we
store that in a private variable I've
just used the single underscore as the
variable name and then we go through we
operate an infinite loop and we call the
done the next method of this object in
order to retrieve the next item in the
iteration if calling that method raises
the stop iteration error then that's the
end of the iteration otherwise we we do
something with I and there's an example
in the notebook here so you can see by
the way that you can't iterate over
everything so if you try and iterate
over none it will say type error nan
type I beg your pardon can I make the
text a bit bigger I would imagine I can
yes
how's that thank you very much yeah so
basically what's happened there is that
the interpreters looked at the
non-object
and it said it doesn't have ADD under it
a method it doesn't ever done the
getitem method I've got no way to
iterate over this thing so if we take a
look at the listing of not all I've done
there is I've taken a list of the
methods and variables accessible from
the non object and you can see that
neither it nor gate item is in there I
suppose another way to do it would have
been to say you know we're present and
present the result of has Afrin on
Donder it er same thing it just says
there is no dunder it a method there is
no dunder getitem method so if we
actually write the the pseudo code for
the list with my test list you can see
that it does actually work perfectly and
the reason that it uses the new
iteration method is because the test
list does indeed have dunder itta method
so if we call that done Doretta method
what do we get back well the answer is
that this is a special type of object so
calling dunder it er which is what I've
done here calling dunder it to create a
list iterator object that is an object
of type list iterator and the actual
fact well we will get around to looking
at it iterators in a minute but before
we do that let's talk about iterables
versus iterators basically we've already
pointed out an iterable object like a
list doesn't have a dunder next method
it has a dunder it a method and when you
call the dunder it a method it produces
something who's done the next method can
be repeatedly called to produce elements
of the sequence and so basically what
that's saying is that when you call and
iterables dunder it a method you're
producing and it
Reiter so an iterator which is a
typically a built-in type created by
some call to a factory function iterate
is the most significant thing about them
is that they have done the next method
but not only do they have done the next
method the typical iterator also has a
dunder ater method so you can actually
iterate over it but the thing that you
need to remember is that although you
can iterate over an iterator the results
if you're not careful will be very
confusing so here we're doing a doubly
nested loop iterating over the test list
and as we would normally expect we're
getting the first element of the first
list with the first element of the
second list first with the second first
with the third then we go to the second
with the first the second with the
second the second with the third and so
on in other words we see a complete
enumeration of all the possibilities and
that's how we expect iteration to work
and the reason that this works is
because whenever we're looping over
something in this code we're first of
all calling the iterables dunder itta
method to create a new iterator so what
happens if instead of using an iterable
we use an iterator and here I'm using a
syntactic shortcut that I'll remind you
about later on basically you can call
something's dunder it a method by
applying the itta function to it that's
just the same as if you can you can call
it's done the len method by applying the
the Len function to it so in this case
I've created two separate iterators and
in the outer loop I ate right over it to
what iterator one in the inner loop I
iterate over iterator to and then I
produce a result which which
includes both values so the first time
through the outer loop we entered the
inner loop for the first time and we see
the first value with the first value
then we go through the inner loop a
second time so we see the first value
with the second value then the third
time so we see the first value with the
the third value so that's the first time
through this loop we've actually used
the value Roberta which is the first
value from this iterator here so then
we've terminated this inner iteration we
go back out to the outer iteration and
we get the second value so now we print
out a loop again but of course at this
point iterator too has been completely
exhausted and because it's an iterator
when the for loop mechanism calls its
dunder it method it just produces itself
and so the first call to the next method
of that iterator immediately raises a
stop iteration error so the second and
third iterations through the outer loop
don't actually produce anything because
the iterator in the inner loop was
exhausted by the first trip around that
loop so that's what happens if you use
two different iterate as it gets even
more confusing if you try to use the
same iterator in both necessary both
values of the nested loop because there
we actually extract the first value from
iterator one we print the fact that
we've entered the outer loop and then of
course here we get the second value from
that iterator so the first thing that we
see is the first value from the iterator
associated with the second value from
the iterator then we loop round again
and call next on that iterator again so
we see the first value with the third
value and then that means it's the end
of this iteration so it goes back out to
the outer loop and of course
iterating over something that it's just
exhausted in the inner loop and so we
don't actually see any more executions
of the inner loop at all and that can be
a little confusing if you're not
expecting that sort of behavior so the
difference between an iterator and an
iterable is that whereas an iterator
will have both an eater and the next
method the iterable only has the eater
method you can see here when we look at
test lists it does have a dunder itta
but it doesn't have it on the next and
when we looked at the iterable itself
then it has both so there we've just got
the code I was demonstrating this is
just to show you that you get an
entirely different result I'm printing
out the IDS of the list and of the two
separate iterators created by calling
the list under it a method so what I'm
trying to underline there is every time
you call an object dunder it a method
you get a new iterator you don't get the
same iterator because if we had the same
iterator as we've seen that can lead to
big trouble so that's just the code that
I was showing you there the code I was
showing you there and the code I was
showing you there so what I'm doing here
is I'm just creating an iterator from
test list and then I'm showing you that
when you call the when you call an
iterators dunder it a method you just
get the same iterator back and the point
of this this last value here is just to
show that indeed says false because the
idea of iterator 3 is not the same as
the identity of calling
iterator threes ID there are two
different objects
now using iterators allow you to adopt
some interesting techniques and one of
the things that you can do is you can
create an iterator and then you can call
its next object inside a loop and you
might think that that's wonderful and
marvelous but again you have to be
careful because here we've got two
iterators with different sequence
lengths so the point behind this loop is
to try to test both of these iterators
so when I test iterating over it.4
everything works nicely right what I'm
doing here is in the inner loop I'm
taking pairs by using the for loop
mechanism to take the first element and
then sneakily moving the iterator along
by calling its next mechanism so with a
sequence with an even number of values
that works very nicely so we get one and
two the first time through the loop we
get three and four the second time
through the loop and then the for loop
tries to call the iterators next again
it sees a stop iteration exception and
so it terminates unfortunately if we use
an iterator that's got an odd number of
values in its sequence then what happens
is that the first two loop mechanism
first two trips around the loop work
exactly the same but then the for loop
manages to extract another value from
the iterator with it's done the next
method but when we call next here you
can see that the call to next actually
raises the stop iteration exception so
that's not terribly helpful now the
really important reason for wanting to
understand the iteration protocol oh by
the way these are just you know in the
same way that Len of object is
equivalent to object dunder land in the
same way there are functions in Python
itter and next which you can use to call
those magic methods that I just thought
I'd
put that in there with a reminder about
the Python - so you can write your own
iterators if you want so here this is
the first piece of the code for an
iterator that I'm writing and the idea
is that the purpose of this iterator is
to produce each character of a given
string a given number of times so the
initializer takes a string and an
integer argument which is stored as
instance variables and then it maintains
a current position and the current count
which both go to 0 and because it's an
iterator it's dunder it a method is
extremely simple it just returns itself
so we can actually use this thing in a
for loop if we want to by virtue of its
ident method but the real magic is in
the dunder next method here so in this
case we're saying well okay if the
current position is equal to the length
of the string then we haven't got any
more characters and so we can raise a
stop iteration otherwise the result is
the character at the current position
however if after incrementing the count
we see that we have returned this
character the correct number of times
then we move on to the next character
and we set the count back so that we can
return the same value for fall exactly
that we can return the same value sorry
the value of the next string and I don't
think I'm actually yes there we go so
here's the same code in the ipython
notebook and hopefully when I've defined
that we will find that if I call that
this basically says this is a iterator
which will return each string of the
each character of the string ABC two
times and lo and behold it does we get
two A's 2 B's and two c's
and here we're using it in a doubly
nested loop and again with a platinum hi
sorry at times in a plus and in equals
and a minus we get x equals x equals x
equals x - x - x - but there of course
since we could these are iterators we
see that that concern that we were
talking about earlier on arising because
iterator 7 has been exhausted by the
first location the first loop across
iterator 6 so when we get to the later
elements of iterator 6 there's nothing
left in iterator 7 to handle those loops
whoops um did I actually cover that
slide no I didn't okay so who's used
generators and generator functions in
Python okay good the really nice part
about generators is that they produce a
much easier give you a much easier way
to write your own route rebels so you're
probably noticed on that last slide
that's a horrible method there's all
kinds of counting arithmetic going on
and that kind of stuff so the nice part
about a function with yield in its body
is that the interpreter actually
recognizes that as a special type of
function called a generator function and
when you call it it doesn't execute the
code body it returns an iterator and
then when you call the iterator sorry
when you you you call for the next value
from the iterator it's just an x value
so in other words the yield function
here
this this well it doesn't actually yield
anything in this particular case which
is rather naughty of me basically
generators are iterator than the yield
becomes the return value from the dunder
next call so when it's when the
generators done the next method is
called in an iteration it starts to run
the code of the function body
and when it encounters a yield keyword
in the function body the expression that
is yielded becomes the value of the next
call so here's a simple generator
function range down which simply
reverses the range and then yields each
value rather naughty there I've got a
capital I where it should be a small
line sorry about that typo hadn't
recognized it okay so you can see that
if we just iterate over it lo and behold
we get three to one from a range down of
four and I believe I've got that there
as well yeah there's the range down
iterator so I've created my range down
iterator Oh what happened here do I
still have oh I did I not actually
execute a cell where I di didn't define
me functions did I sorry about that one
of the nice things about the ipython
notebook is you can go back and do
things that you should have done earlier
so now I do have an is it a rebel under
and an is iterative function so you can
see that the type of generator is a
generator it is not an iterable but it
is an iterator and you can also see that
when I actually call that with sorry if
I use it in a loop then I just go down
from 4 to 0 which is range 5 reversed so
here I'm just basically using what's
called a generator expression and again
any expression with the 4 inside it is a
sequence of the expressions before the 4
so again I'm not quite sure oh yeah okay
range down itself is a function but the
generator is a generator and indeed this
generator expression is also a generator
and we know from the cells above that
generators are iterators and so having
created this expression
we can iterate over it because it's an
iterator just like any other generator
come back right so that's generator
expressions the basic iterable pattern
says that you've got to create all your
stuff but the really important thing
about an iterator is that it actually
has to create return that's dunder itter
method has to return a new iterator in
other words the difference between an
iterable and an iterator is that an
iterable like a list uses a factory
function as its dunder it a method so
every time you loop over it
you get a new iterator which is why
lists are well-behaved
in the way that iterators weren't inside
nested loops as we showed in the example
above so we can actually use a generator
as our dunder itter method if we want to
so in this case you can see that this is
a method and because it contains a yield
in its body methods of functions and so
it is a generator and you may wonder
okay I had this I had my Maya to Reiter
up there before but basically you'll
notice that this object here this class
is a subclass of the standard string and
so you may wonder why don't I just
iterate over self instead of iterating
over the STR call and the reason I don't
iterate over self is if I iterate it
over self that would result in a call to
the objects dunder it a method which
would iterate over self and so you do in
fact effectively get an infinite loop of
calls on the dunder Etta method so the
nice thing about this object is because
it inherits from string it does
everything that a Python string will do
so in this case you know there is the
mi string class and so if I create an mi
string then if I iterate over it all I'm
iterating over it using a list
comprehension and then we get three X's
three wise and three Z similarly if we
iterate over it in two nested loops you
can see that now because the separate
iterators are produced for each
iteration over c1 and c2 we still get
the correct behavior we get 0 0 twice 0
1 twice 0 0 twice 0 1 2 and so on and so
forth so they are actually well-behaved
objects and again we can use them just
like we can use strings so if the string
here you know if we create something
here with a value of 0 1 then it acts
like the string 0 1 we can add them we
can multiply them just like we can
because all the rest of their behavior
is being inherited from system strings
so basically here it says the string is
iterable it is not an iterator if we
call it eater
that is not an iterable but it is an
iterator so calling the dunder eater
method or the itter function which is
equivalent on an iterator will on an
iterable will give you an iterator so
there's another string class here where
we're basically doing the same kind of
thing and you can see that that's just
the example I ran above I seem to
remember oh yes but in this case we're
using the generator as the method okay
well we're nearly out of time so that's
pretty much all I actually wanted to
cover there were a few things there that
we could get into but it's not really
important since it's now significantly
almost
time if you have any questions then ask
them now that's my email address and
just as a reminder if you'd like to take
a look at the slides and the notebooks
later on they are available online thank
you very much
I'm sorry how does it work for sex
well yeah basically although the Python
implementation of sets indicts doesn't
guarantee any specific ordering it does
guarantee that if you add the same
values in the same order to two sets you
will get the same iteration sequence so
in actual fact the underlying
representation of the set and the Dictys
is based on hash chaining so there is an
implementation that does put the keys in
a specific sequence it's just that the
sequence doesn't mean anything to us so
it just uses a linear iteration over the
keys yeah good yes you mean can you
change an object while it's being
iterated over well you can but of course
the results aren't aren't guaranteed to
be predictable so for example here if I
if we use that class mi string then
basically I'm iterating over the the
string of of myself so that wouldn't be
a particularly good one to modify and
listen for one that we might poke at as
we iterate over it well okay let's just
hang on a minute get to the bottom of
the notebook there we go
right good so if I say for example class
and one
- dunder init so and we care we don't
even need an init probably but I'll just
put it in there deaf dunder it er so so
let's just say I don't actually but yes
the answer is once you understand the
mechanism then you can understand the
results of being able to tweak now in in
Python 3 for example some of the
iterators of say what people think that
when you iterate over the keys of a dict
it just produces a list of the keys and
then iterates over them but in actual
fact the situation there is much more
complicated they use what's called a
dict view and the result is that the
dick view will actually complain it'll
raise an exception if you try and change
the key set of the dictionary while it's
being iterated over
yeah
it has sort of like myself well this one
here so what were you yeah this one
actually would be something that we
could modify if we wanted oh I see right
okay so what you're saying is if we say
mi equals my iterator so if we use the
list oh okay and better still you say x
equals one two and three right oops okay
and then my iterator over X and we'll
just use doubling right okay
whoops-a-daisy all right so if we
establish that okay so if I now say mi
dot next value from mi then we should
get one right okay which we do so now if
I say X dot since zero position zero
don't worry I'm used to it I always yeah
thank you
there we go whoops I'm not even sure why
I got away with that I must have an
object called Oh clearly somewhere there
we go that's what I meant to do but
anyway now if we say next of MI again if
we just execute that cell again then we
get zero so yes in this particular case
you can tweak around with the underlying
iterable that you're iterating over and
it will actually see the changes
pleasure yes in this epical case where
I'm getting some access to a database
cursor or something like that yep
produced an iterator off deck
yep basically well yeah but you clearly
you have to be careful there well I
would say that database cursors don't
make a particularly good iterable
precisely because of the need to store
all the values effectively if you're if
you're going to do that then I as far as
I'm aware most of the the only the
database cursors I know of the art that
you can iterate over they're actually
it's a raters or sorry the results of
the cursor execute they're actually
iterators rather than iterables so in
other words when once you've iterated
over the the cursor having executed a
query then if you try and iterate over
it again without executing another query
you'll just get an empty result because
the iteration will have been exhausted
you could do that but whether you'd
actually want to or not you know you'd
have to be being alert to the
implications because if you want to be
effectively if you wanted to refresh the
series of values that we're coming out
of the database the only two ways to do
that are either to store it when you
make the query and you know retrieve it
all which obviously wouldn't be
convenient in the case of a large query
or to repeat the query with each call of
done dorita so there are sometimes a
price to be paid and that's why it's
worthwhile understanding the iteration
mechanism
that's a nice new birth so thank you
again thanks very much